hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar cell dive transforming tissue
research with open multiplexing
I am Kaylee Bach of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by Leica Microsystems to learn more
visit Leica Dash microsystems.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speakers
Katie white cell dive product manager at
Leica Microsystems and Michael Smith
celldive application manager at Leica
Microsystems I'll now pass it over to
Ava to get things started
hello this is Ava Anson welcoming you to
this bite size bio webinar which today
is sponsored by Leica Microsystems
today's presentation is titled cell dive
transforming tissue research with open
multiplexing and it's being presented by
Katie white and Michael Smith from Leica
Microsystems
Katie is the product manager for the
cell dive Multiplex Imaging solution at
Leica Microsystems she studied
mechanical engineering as an
undergraduate at the University of
Delaware and completed a master's degree
in biomedical engineering at the
University of New South Wales
Katie began working with microscopes in
2008 as a field application scientist
for a high-resolution wide field
microscopy system
she has worked as a sales specialist in
global product support specialist for
high resolution super resolution and
high content Imaging systems
Michael is the application manager for
sale dive he completed a PhD in the
genetics of DNA repair at Columbia
University and a postdoctoral fellowship
in genome integrity and cellular aging
at Memorial Sloan Kettering Cancer
Center where he leveraged microscopy to
understand the real-time dynamics of DNA
homeostasis
his passion for answering biological
questions using Imaging Technologies led
him to his current position where he
provides technical expertise and
customer support for the sale dive
platform
as always we will have a question and
answer session after the presentation so
please type any questions you have into
the questions box which appears on the
bottom of your screen and I'll put them
to Katie and Michael at the end the
recording of the webinar will be
available at bytetouchbio.com so now
over to you Michael for the presentation
so thank you very much for that kind
introduction
um so today to give you a working
example of how cell dive can help to
transform your tissue research with
Multiplex Imaging I'm going to focus on
a pancreatic cancer example
um pancreatic cancer is one of the
highest mortality rates of any cancer
the pancreas is surrounded by a lot of
Highly vascularized organs such as the
duodenum the bile duct and pancreatic
cancer often invades and metastasis
metastasizes to even more distant organs
uh like the liver the peritoneum the
brain the kidney and Bone and
unfortunately conventional chemotherapy
plus radiation or in advanced diseases
chemotherapy plus targeted drug
therapies
um they can lengthen survival but really
they have a fairly low success rate uh
The Five-Year survival rate for these
patients is about 40
um and I think this demonstrates a lot
of Need for improved therapies for all
pancreatic cancer patients including new
uh novel therapies such as
immunotherapies
so we're coming to understand more and
more
um in the current kind of scientific
know you that tumors are not monoliths
they're structurally and
organizationally complex that have lots
of different tissues and systems
operating within them and kind of
collectively all these tissues and
systems are known as the tumor
microenvironment and it's becoming
increasingly clear how essential
understanding that micro environment is
for under developing and using novel
therapies different reasons of the tumor
like the stroma can behave differently
from other regions in the context of the
disease and the contributions of all
these different regions can underlie the
often quite different responses the
different patients display when treated
with these emerging therapies Beyond
just the stroma there are some reasons
within the tumor that can adapt to
certain metabolic conditions such as the
presence or absence of strong
concentrations of oxygen so you can have
regions that are both normoxic and
hypoxic within the same tumor
um and often these hypoxic sub-regions
within the tumor can adapt to those
conditions and actually gain dominance
over the other tissues
um by uncontrolled cell growth and as a
result these hypoxia adaptive tissues
are often more aggressive so you're just
using a small subset of biomarkers maybe
looking at five biomarkers two tumor two
blood vessel and one stroma you can see
that hypoxic regions of the tumor can be
effectively classified compared to the
normoxic tissue and it's important to
note here that five biomarkers is
exceeding kind of the conventional
traditional microscopy methods for
analysis in the same area of a slide and
really five markers only scratches the
surface of the information you need to
understand the biological complexity of
these tissues so clearly more biomarkers
are needed to characterize the cell
heterogeneity in these complex tumor
microenvironments
um so what we wanted to do in this case
is Leverage The Power of cell by to look
at many more markers than just five and
probe other biological Pathways in
concert to see how these uh tumor cells
might be surviving and becoming more
aggressive so we have a kind of General
hypothesis to explore at this experiment
which is that the tumor cells in these
hypoxic regions adapt to avoid program
cell death and evade the cellular immune
response which would otherwise curtail
their growth
so I'm going to show kind of a bird's
eye view of a few different kind of
biomarker panels all of these are imaged
in the same slide in the same experiment
just kind of separated so we can look at
different biological Pathways to show
that the different phenomenon that you
can look at in a single cell life
experiment so first we have a collection
of markers to explore metabolism such as
aerobic glycolysis and the Warburg
effect and what this is going to show is
the regions of the tumor that are
hypoxic and ormoxic
and to explore the apoptosis question
we've layered in some biomarkers such as
caspase to look at which cells are
undergoing apoptosis at a higher or
lower rate in the same tissue
and lastly we're going to look at some
traditional immune cell markers to
explore the Recruitment and um
differentiation and multiplication of
immune cells within that tissue
so when we have all this data
the experiment becomes very complex
because we have many biomarkers and many
cells to explore so what we are able to
do
is perform a clustering algorithm first
we'll do some cellular phenotyping and
apply a clustering algorithm called a
umap to this data to separate these
cells into different functional clusters
and then explore kind of which biomarker
systems are presence in each of these
clusters uh and so this is done by the
layering of dozens of biomarkers to
identify these differences that are not
going to be obvious from just looking at
a few biomarkers
um
and so in this cluster diagram each
biomarker is along the x-axis and cells
are clustered based on biomarker
expression similarities across the
tissue
so for example based on the epithelial
markers pck 26 and ae1 and the umap
spatial relationships we're going to be
able to identify normal pancreas and
visualize the Clusters that are separate
from the tumor cell cluster so that
would be numbers four and six here
um and if we click again
we can see
um normoxic tumor tissue and a click
again
and now we see hypoxic tumor tissue so
they all cluster separately and one of
the major determinants here we're just
looking at this along the axis of glute
one which is a marker for those hypoxic
conditions and you can see that when Glu
bond is not present it's not commonly
present in the normoxic normal tissue
nor is it present in the normoxic tumor
tissue but in cluster three down at the
bottom you have a high glute one
expression indicating that hypoxia so
we're able to Cluster these away from
the other cells in the population
so where does apoptosis fall into this
um
so we have a couple of markers that we
can look at to kind of explore uh the
presence of apoptosis uh undergoing
cells in this population so we're going
to look at back in caspase nine it's
kind of two traditional apoptosis
markers
and we can see that even among the
non-tumor tissue within the pancreas
there are some cells that are low in
apoptosis and some cells that are high
in apoptosis
and what we find is that in the normoxic
tumor tissue that expresses a low level
of glute one we find a higher level of
apoptosis but if we take a look at the
tumor tissue that's hypoxic what we find
is a lower level of these apotonic
markers indicating that by some
mechanism these hypoxic cells are
avoiding apoptosis
and lastly we'll look at immune cells so
we're going to use
um four different markers we'll use CD3
which is a sorry three different markers
C3 which is a T Cell marker as well as
CD4 and cd8 to identify those
subpopulations of T cells and we can see
that they cluster away from the uh
clusters A9 cluster away from that
hypoxic tumor tissue in cluster three so
these regions are kind of immune cell
deserts and there's very limited
recruitment of immune cells into these
hypoxic regions which might be another
reason that they're able to survive and
become more aggressive
so our finding uh using this panel is
that cancer cells in these hypoxic
regions do in fact adapt to avoid
apoptosis and they simultaneously are
able to evade immune activity
so the impression I want to leave you
with here is that
um
you know obviously tumor cells and tumor
microenvironments are incredibly
complicated and there are multiple
biological Pathways that are kind of at
play and interacting with each other in
these cells and if we were limited to
just looking at five or six biomarkers
we wouldn't be able to understand any of
these into relationships we wouldn't
understand that the hypoxic tissue also
reduces recruitment of the apoptotic
markers are also
um you know lowers the recruitment of
immune cells but through doing a
multiplex Imaging experiment with cell
dive we're able to see how all of these
biomarkers interrelate to each other and
Come Away with a deeper understanding of
the underlying biology here so celldive
can reveal these relationships between
many different types of biological
Pathways that just wouldn't be clear
using other Imaging methods
so what is Multiplex Imaging can we can
we zoom out and kind of understand what
uh this this kind of emerging technique
is and so I think there are a lot of
definitions floating around for what
Multiplex Imaging means but I think the
basic understanding is any type of
Imaging experiment
that is able to
um
look at more markers than a traditional
microscopy experiment
um and so that might be you know
traditionally four or five different
markers
um and so anything beyond that could be
considered Multiplex Imaging so we have
kind of a differentiation uh based on
the number of markers
um so a lower uh or a more midplex
experiment might look at something like
six to ten markers and this might be
accomplished through something like
spectral and mixing many different
fluorophores are present in the sample
and they're able to use software and
Optics to separate those uh different
um
Spectra and then visualize the different
markers if you want to go beyond just
six to ten markers and look into to many
more like we've done in this experiment
here it's important to use something
like an iterative hyperplex system and
so what this does is it uses multiple
rounds of staining and either bleaching
or dying activation or stripping of
antibodies to iteratively probe and
re-visualize the sample and you can see
in these images at the bottom that
multiple biomarkers are being layered on
top of each other with each round and
this really allows you to get past the
kind of traditional limitations of these
platforms and look at many more markers
10 20 30 40 50 60 100.
um and celldive is part of this family
of Technologies
so there are a lot of considerations and
I'm sure people who are considering this
space probably have a lot of questions
about how to get started uh and there
are a lot of questions that can go
through the mind of the researcher such
as
can I get started quickly um these seem
like complicated experiments is it going
to be something I can pick up or is it
going to require uh lead times to bring
in the technology that are kind of
unacceptable in a fast-moving research
space
can I design studies to answer my unique
question is this going to be flexible
enough to be able to be applicable to
what I'm studying you know researchers
are looking at very
um specific issues and specific parts of
tumors is this going to work for my
unique system
and am I going to be able to adapt this
study if my research needs change or
grow over time am I going to be able to
be flexible with this or am I going to
be locked into some kind of Kit or
method that might not work throughout
the lifetime of my research
can I return to my slides for Downstream
processing or more imaging I'm sure
we've all had experiments that we wish
we could have gone back to and just
looked at one or two more things some of
these methods are destructive and
especially with precious or expensive
tissues that can be a real challenge so
am I going to be able to go back and
have the flexibility to add in a few
markers if my research question evolves
during the study
is the workflow reliable is it going to
be something that produces uh the same
kind of results every time on similar
tissues or is it going to produce swings
and batch effects that are going to make
analysis more challenging
can I trust the data
um is this going to be replicable from
the beginning of one study to the end of
the study which could be months or years
later is it going to be replicable in a
different lab is it going to be
replicable many years later can I trust
the data
and am I going to be able to scale up if
I need to if I start an experiment that
looks at 10 slides of tissue but I
decide I want to move up to 100 or a
thousand is this technology going to be
able to grow with me and my needs
and lastly am I going to get the high
quality image data I need for robust
analysis of course everything
um that's extracted from Imaging data
sets depends on the quality of those
images and if these image quality isn't
uh good enough then we can get uh
incorrect or unreliable uh analysis from
that so am I going to have the image
quality to actually get results I can
trust
so I'm going to kick it over to Katie
white our product manager here at cell
lab to tell you more about how Cell live
can answer and help you with some of
those important questions and bring the
world of multiplexing to you
thank you Michael uh for a great
introduction to the power of
multiplexing and in this next section
I'd like to tell you a little bit more
about cell Dives specifically
so what is celldive at first glance you
might assume it's an automated integer
but really it's a complete multiplexed
Imaging solution
and this graphic here shows the
components of the celldive solution
the first component is the validated
antibody list and this is a list of over
350 rigorously validated antibodies that
have been proven to work with this elder
process
and doing this type of validation takes
considerable time and money so access to
this list is a huge productivity
JumpStart
second we have the the patented workflow
for celldive and this iterative staining
and dying activation workflow is what
allows us to stain an image a sample
repeatedly with new biomarkers in each
round
next up is the acquisition software and
built into this software is a huge
amount of Technology around image
calibration and correction
and these calibrations and Corrections
ensures that these large rois that we
collect for cell Dives can be seamlessly
stitched and precisely aligned to enable
Downstream single cell analysis
the next is the the cell dive imager and
it is a very robust automated microscope
with a number of customizations to make
it a dedicated tissue imager including
an onboard barcode reader five channel
capability and compatibility with
automation systems for sample loading
the final component is the analysis
software and in this space we've
partnered with Indica labs and also
their tissue pathology software called
Halo and this software is very well
known in the tissue analysis space for
balancing power and ease of use really
well
so on that last slide I talked through
the components of the cell type solution
but that doesn't really explain how cell
type works and what you see here is a
high level overview of the cell type
workflow We Begin our process with your
tissue sample and the first thing that
we do is we prepare those samples using
a well-defined slide preparation process
that it includes a patented antigen
retrieval technique but also more
standard processes like de-waxing
clearing Etc
so after the slides are prepared we put
them on the imager and we use Quick low
magnification scans to define the region
or regions that will be imaged for the
study
when that's complete we get into the
iterative part of the study the Imaging
ground first we stain with up to four
dye conjugated antibodies we perform our
biomarker Imaging and then we inactivate
the dyes or turn them off with our
chemical dying activation solution
so this process doesn't remove
antibodies or photobly to the sample so
it's very gentle in tissue preserving
this is the step that allows us to stain
over and over with new antibodies
when that's complete we image our
autofluorescence or autofluorescent
signal again and these images are used
for computational autofluorescence
removal and then that concludes an
Imaging around
so those four steps are repeated for
different biomarkers until the study is
complete
from there images are used as input to
image analysis programs to do
comprehensive segmentation
classification and spatial analysis of
the sample to answer research questions
so in this section I'd like to explore
in a bit more detail what we really mean
when we say that soundive is an open
multiplexing system
so we know that getting started with
multiplexing can be overwhelming
especially when it comes to building
panels and to help you get started with
confidence cell dive comes with an
extensive list of 350 antibodies that
have been rigorously characterized to
ensure they will work with the selling
process
and you can leverage that and build your
panel entirely with antibodies from this
list or you can use the cell The Proven
cell type characterization process to
validate your own antibodies
um additionally being an open
multiplexing system means that we're
agnostic to the method you choose for
multiplexing so if you'd like to use a
third-party multiplexing kit or you use
one of the open source multiplexing
methods you can do that with cell
divides
it's also important to mention that we
don't dictate where you Source your
antibodies or reagents so you're free to
use the suppliers that you like and
Trust while simultaneously keeping your
costume
finally I think their real power comes
from the fact that you can combine any
or all of these strategies to build your
completely custom panel
uh for example
um you can begin with an eight marker
multiplexing kit that covers maybe some
core immune cell markers supplement with
a number of markers from the cell type
validated antibody list and then add in
a few of your favorite antibodies that
you validated yourself and voila you
have a biomarker panel that is
completely customized to your specific
research question
with celldive you're also free to choose
what you'd like to image so depending on
what you're interested in you can decide
to image your whole tissue select a
single area up to 20 by 45 millimeters
in size which is huge or you could
identify smaller regions of interest to
examine specific structures
Imaging areas aren't constrained to any
size or shape either so you can image
exactly what you need but only what you
need
set of Protocols are also incredibly
comprehensive as well so they detail all
steps of multiplexing workflow including
bench work steps QC steps and of course
Imaging steps and this ensures that the
right processes happen at the right time
for the right samples
but even with the most well-designed
protocol you might need to Pivot or
change something while the study isn't
processed and that's possible with cell
Dives
so maybe early examination of your data
gives you a new Avenue to explore
it's not an issue you can add a couple
more rounds of Imaging at the end of
your study
or maybe a great new biomarker of
Interest becomes available a year after
you complete a study and if you saved
the slides you can pull them out of the
fridge and you can stain them again
but still type it's never too late to
adapt your study design to respond to
your research questions
so uh scalability and efficiency is
important important to everyone not just
as it pertains to multiplexing but to
scientific research generally so how can
celldive help you become more efficient
and help you scale your work
so when you think about scalability if
you're like me you immediately picture
sort of hardware for automation
um but without a framework and software
to enable that automation it kind of
doesn't work
the automation Hardware needs to know
what to do with your samples and this
tracking becomes even more complex with
multiplexing where you may have many
samples or even studies running
concurrently and somehow you need to
keep track of what to do next with each
and every slide
and that framework or backbone of
Multiplex study management was one of
the driving forces behind the
development of the celldive acquisition
software
so with input from an integrated barcode
reader in the imager the software
automatically tracks slides through a
multiplexing study and performs exactly
the right action for that slide at
exactly the right time
in addition to tracking multiple slides
the hit the software can handle multiple
studies at a time making it perfect for
a multi-user environment or just a busy
lab balancing multiple studies or
cohorts at the same time
the software also plays a big role in
compatibility with automation once a
protocol is defined and regions are
selected for all slides there is no user
interaction required in subsequent
Imaging steps this slide is loaded the
barcode is read and the system knows
exactly what to do according to the
protocol and this allows for easy
integration with automation
so another aspect of this celldive
workflow that allows for scalability is
how slides can be processed in batches
and to explore this in more detail
lesson let's examine this graphic of the
iterative portion of the cell type
workflow in this workflow we have two
bench work steps where we actually
manipulate the sample and those are the
biomarker staining and die and
activation steps and we have two Imaging
steps where the slides are image
and with celldive the benchwork steps
happen off the integer which allows for
batch processing slides through those
steps
we take a closer look at what that
manual workflow would look like for
maybe three slides this is kind of what
we would see so each of the scientist
icons around the outside of this cycle
represents a touch point in the cycle
and its size roughly represents the
duration that
so if we start from the top left
biomarker staining which is a benchmark
step
you can see that there are a couple
touch points here that are kind of
longish in duration
and as we move into biomarker Imaging we
have three touch points so in this
example we have one for each slide that
we're processing
but they're very short just the amount
of time to load each slide into the
imager and push go
and that pattern is repeated on the
bottom half of that cycle for dying
activation a couple longer touch points
to perform diode Dion activation on all
sides at once and then short touch
points to load the slides into the
integer one by one
and this batch processing workflow is
advantageous for a few very important
reasons
so number one since all slides in a
study can move through the eventwork
steps together you can have confidence
that they've been treated as similarly
as possible you'll be staining with the
same antibody Solution on the same day
the environmental conditions will be the
same the incubation times will be the
same Etc
the workflow also enables you to scale
your research even if you don't have the
means to automate the process so whether
you're working on three slides or ten
The Benchmark portion of this workflow
doesn't change much touch points get
slightly longer to address more samples
but it certainly doesn't scale linearly
with the number of slides
and finally the fact that benchworth
steps happen off the Imager
allows you to keep that imager working
as much as possible
it doesn't have to sit around when
slides are being stained or going
through dye inactivation that time can
be used for other slides other users and
other studies
so so what about Automation in my years
of talking with researchers in this
space one thing is a recurring theme
everyone wants Automation and
multiplexing but not everyone wants the
same automation
so from those who would like to just set
it and forget it for two to three slides
to those that need complete staining and
imaging automation for cohorts of 50 or
more slides one thing is very clear a
one-size-fits-all approach to automation
just doesn't work
and this is why I think it's so
important this in this space to enable
automation but allow you to dictate what
that automation looks like based upon
the throughput you require your budget
or your access to existing equipment
so for cell dive automation is enabled
by the clickwell coverslip free
slideholder and clickwill is unique
because it allows you to perform all of
your benchmark and imaging steps right
in the click while or allows you to
repeatedly remove and reinstall slides
from the clickwell for processing
elsewhere
so what are some of the ways that the
cell type workflow can be automated
so in looking at this manual workflow
the thing that jumps out to me first
especially if you'll be Imaging a larger
number of slides would be to eliminate
the touch points in each of the Imaging
quadrants
and uh clickwell was designed with the
footprint of a standard multi-well plate
so nearly any robotic arm can be
integrated into the system to
automatically load plates into and out
of the Imager
and with that type of automation the
touch more points for a biomarker
labeling and die in activation are bench
work steps they wouldn't change but
we've already discussed that even with a
larger number of slides those steps can
still be done for all slides in a batch
fashion
and after the bench work steps are
complete there would be one touch point
in the beginning of the Imaging segment
to load the slides into the input stack
for the robotic arm and initiate the
Imaging process from there slides would
be loaded into the imager and imaged one
by one into all slides have been imaged
and that one automation step increases
the amount of unintended time really
significantly so that means that
for the entire Imaging time for all
slides you're free to perform other
tasks it can also enable overnight
Imaging to allow you to take advantage
of every hour of their day
we also hear from researchers that they
would like to automate The Benchmark
parts of this process and and that's
possible with uh with clickwell as well
so the repeatable slide positioning and
the ability to easily install and remove
slides from clickwell allows for the use
of commercial Auto standards to automate
staining and diet activation
and this diagram shows what that
workflow would look like when you
combine the robotic arm with a
commercial Auto stainer to automate The
Benchmark parts of the process
similar to the manual workflow the
slides would be processing the auto
standard in a batch fashion
as for touch points in this type of
workflow there are just four at each of
the transitions between the auto stainer
and robotic arm or vice versa
and again this expands the unattended
time between touch points even with very
very large number of slides
the last thing about this open approach
is that it also enables your level of
automation to scale with your research
so maybe today a manual workflow is fine
but in a year you get a huge Grant for a
major study and with celldive you can do
that type of scale up just by adding
supporting equipment not additional
images
so we do have one more automation option
to make this process even a little bit
more hands-off and this is a new
solution that we've developed
exclusively for celldive with Advanced
Solutions like Sciences
it's a customization of their bio
assembly bot 200 platform to completely
automate a full half round of
staining and imaging for cellos
and the cool thing about this solution
is that it's a robotic arm with
interchangeable attachments in this case
an automated pipettor and a plate
gripper that allows us to automate both
staining and imaging or Diet activation
and imaging to further expand the ones
at the time
and with this solution there are only
two touch points per round so you load
up to 15 slides you set up the system
with required reagents and tips and you
push go
on this slide we see um the bio assembly
about working on a set of slides and
click well slide holders
in this scenario the bench works done in
this scenario benchwork steps are done
directly in the clickwell by pipetting
reagents in and out so we can do the
entire staining or die inactivation
process right in the click well and we
can do it for up to 15 slides at a time
bab also comes with pre-configured bio
apps that cover all the main workflows
for cell nut so that includes staining
Dion activation and even an image only
mode that allows Fab to just act as a
simple plate motor so there's nearly no
overhead to getting started
and as you can see here Fab and
celldiver integrated seamlessly so bad
performs all the steps for staining or
die in activation then can load samples
directly into the cell diameter and the
imager does the rest it will carry out
the right Imaging actions based upon the
slides barcode protocol
so essentially you load the slides and
when you come back everything is done
you just get to review final stitched
images for quality control
finally these custom workflows were
designed specifically to keep the imager
busy so anytime there is a slide that's
finished Imaging there is another slide
right behind it that's ready to start
last but certainly not least how do you
know you can trust the data you get from
cell Dives
multiplexing has exploded in popularity
in recent years and it seems like every
day there's a new system our new product
in this space and like on Microsystems
might not be the first company you think
about when you think about spatial
biology but celldive and the technology
that it's based upon has a long history
in this space
the sell-off platform and the workflow
has been in development for over a
decade in fact the first paper was
published way back in 2008
and since then countless hours from both
the developers of the technology as well
as prominent early adopted worldwide
have gone into testing refining and
validating the entire cell type workflow
there have also been uh 40 over 40
peer-reviewed Publications that leverage
cell diabetes in years
and finally as a real life application
for this type of technology celldive has
been used in biopharma since 2015 as a
robust way to stratified patient
populations for clinical
so this iterative staining workflow is
the backbone of the cell type process so
it would be the backbone of your
research as well
for something so important it's
imperative that it just works and it
works the first time and it works every
time
and the years of research that have used
this process guarantee just that so you
can get started with confidence in that
workflow
over the years collaborators have run
some huge studies with this process so
that we know it works for 60 plus
biomarkers the largest study that was
done used over 120 biomarkers
but it's also proven to be very gentle
so at the end of your studies your
tissue is still intact and can be used
for Downstream processing uh to be
stored or to revisit in the future
and finally our patented two-step image
of retrieval has been shown to provide
better antibody binding and increased
staining intensity for better quality
data
next up is the cell div imager and and
this this is what Leica does this is
what we're known for making high quality
microscope systems and this cell dive
imager is no exception
this purpose-built fully automated
tissue Imaging system was engineered for
precision
speed and sensitivity to make sure our
images match match the quality you
expect from Leica but more importantly
uh so that you get robust Downstream
analysis results
we can also capture nearly the entire
imageable area of microscope so you
aren't Limited in the size of the tissue
you would like to say about
and finally we all we all know the pain
of Imaging a very very large sample and
then having just a few out of focus
frames to ruin it and this thought I've
taken a cell type imager takes advantage
of advanced slide mapping and multiple
Auto autofocus routines to ensure every
frame is in Focus every time
so uh I'm a microscopist that's that's
sort of my background so I love to look
at beautiful image data but the truth of
the matter is that the images that we
get are really a means to an end it's
the data the analysis results that we
get Downstream that we use to generate
insight
and while that's absolutely true I don't
think we can minimize the importance of
good image data to start with because
even the most advanced analysis
pipelines can't fix poor images it's
that whole garbage and garbage out idea
and the celldive software takes the
guesswork and the effort out of getting
to your final image our custom
calibration plate automatic calibration
routine was developed over 10 years to
produce seamlessly stitched and
precisely aligned Multiplex data
and the images here are a great example
so what we see here is sub nuclear
registration structures from different
rounds we have Ki 67 from round one of
Imaging and dappy from round three and
even those those were imaged at two
totally different rounds we get that
perfect registration between the channel
and the best thing about the whole
process the calibration and correction
process is that it's completely
automatic you run the automatic
calibration routine once a month and
those calibrations are automatically
applied to your images such that all you
see is the final press product a
corrected stitched and aligned data set
these calibrations also enable
correlation across multiple samples
multiple studies and even multiple
integers
so to summarize uh Michael showed us a
great example of how Multiplex damaging
can answer complex questions that can't
be fully explored with other Imaging
methods
we also highlighted how open
multiplexing with cell dive let your
research dictate how you run your
multiplexing study including how to
build your antibody panel which
antibodies to use and even the level of
automation that's
finally I hope we've shown that
regardless of how you choose to proceed
with your study the data quality you get
from celldive doesn't change you'll
always get Crystal Clear whole tissue
images enable you to deepen your
understanding of the tissue micro
environment through outstanding spatial
mapping of single cell
thank you all for joining us today we
appreciate your time
turn it over for some questions
thank you Michael and Katie for your
informative presentation before we
proceed with our q a session we ask that
you participate in a series of poll
questions that will be displayed on your
screen
so we'll go ahead and proceed with those
our first question here do you currently
use multiplexed Imaging in your research
please select one of these answers on
your screen
again the question is do you currently
use multiplexed Imaging in your research
all right we'll proceed to the next
question what method do you currently
use to analyze tissue selections please
select all that apply
again what method do you currently use
to analyze tissue selections
in our last question here are you
interested in learning more about cell
dive
like your answer
great thank you so much
all right we've got Katie and Michael
here wonderful we will now start the
live q a portion of the webinar if you
have a question you'd like to ask please
do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for so let's
get started
all right our first question here is for
Michael Michael how long does it take to
validate an antibody and how much does
it cost
that's a great question
um if you're looking to bring in an
antibody
um that's not currently on the cell
diverted antibodies list we provide
instructions for a pretty exhaustive
three-step process for validating
antibodies and we estimate that it would
take around 32 hours of Labor and about
1500 to 3 000 in reagent costs to go
through that process of the per antibody
basis
great thank you next question here is
also for Michael what type of image
correction does celldive perform
so the cell type imager comes with a
specialized calibration plate
um that's loaded into the imager and is
used to perform a variety of Corrections
that Ensure High Imaging quality without
a lot of intervention and
Corrections done manually by the user
and there are I believe over 10
different Corrections that go into the
system but just to list a few of those
the objectives are centered there are
blank glass artifacts that are
subtracted we perform flat field
Corrections intensity calibrations
Distortion Corrections stage alignment
and of course image alignment
registration and autofluorescence is
removed from each image based on an
autofluorescence image not off the
calibration plate so there are a variety
of different um routine Imaging
calibrations that are performed without
user intervention
great thank you
Katie this next question is for you to
do multiplexing at scale do you have to
automate
they're great that's a great question
and the answer there is no so we have
customers that
um are doing multiplexing from at scale
and using either a fully automated
solution or not automating at all doing
everything manually and as um as we kind
of mentioned in the webinar
um
to to do
the cell dive process manually whether
you're doing two slides or ten slides
um the workflow really doesn't change
all that much especially with the bench
work you know a lot of the time in bench
work processes is spent
um you know getting your reagents mixing
up the solutions that you need to use
and whether you're doing two slides or
ten slides that only needs to be done
once and then you just need to sort of
either pipette those reagents onto two
slides or ten slides or you know dip
them into a staining dish so we do have
customers that run studies with you know
10 20 30 slides and they do it all
completely manually so it is possible
great thank you another question for you
Katie the advertising says there is a
list of validated conjugated primary
antibodies for use in cell dive where do
I find this list
so that list is actually part of the
solution so when you purchase the system
that list comes along with the system
um for you to use to design your study
so it is not something that we we give
away it there is a lot of value in the
list
um so as Michael mentioned to validate
each of those antibodies it takes 32
hours of time and fifteen hundred to
three thousand dollars so that is
something that we sell as a part of the
solution
great thank you
and Katie another question for you here
can the imager do thicker sections 30
microns 50 microns
that's a great one um so so the short
answer there is no so celldive isn't
inherently 2D Imaging solution so
um we advise our customers that tissue
sections around three to five microns
thick is where where we need to be
um and the the one thing to consider
when you're thinking about doing
multiplexing
um on thicker samples is the volume of
data so if you are doing whole tissue
Imaging and you're doing it through 30
microns or 50 microns
um just the Avalanche of data that is
produced
um and the difficulties that would be
there for Downstream analysis can be
cannot be underestimated but um short
answer cell dive is a 2d tissue imager
2D multiplexing system
great thank you well we will go ahead
and wrap up there Michael Katie do you
have any final comments for our audience
no I don't think so
thank you so much for your attention
wonderful well thank you again Michael
and Katie for your time today and your
important research we would also like to
thank lab roots and our sponsor Leica
Microsystems for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
lab Roots will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time take care everyone
goodbye